hi I'm Jeff Goldblum this is the wired
auto-complete interview I'm in fact not
wise I'm wired internally in a certain
way yes I do have I don't have a son I
have two sons does Jeff Goldblum have a
stutter
no not in the conventional sense
but I do fun for a lot thumper is kind
of a yeah yeah I got a guy like that but
it's my own that's an affectation of my
own making not an involuntary Oh
does Jeff die in Jurassic Park
- no of course I don't die i prevail and
and the the great animals are let out in
San Diego and me and Julianne we get
enough and it's convertible and we does
Jeff doping song well I think you've you
got to check your syntax and grammar
there but I think song if a verb song
can be barbed yes I do song and I'll
song for you right now some enchanted
evening you may me to this stranger what
is Jeff Goldblum famous for if you don't
know I'm not going to tell you if you
don't know me that I'm not famous for
anything is Jeff Goldblum dead or alive
this could be it we may be in some
multiverse where I don't even exist how
tall is Jeff Goldblum in feet well of
course I'm six foot four and a scotch
where is Jeff Goldblum from Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania
oh the rolling hills of Pennsylvania
finest state in all the land with its
hills and phezzan rolling valleys what
is Jeff Goldblum's
character's job what character you're
talking about mr. Google you got to tell
me more specifically if you're talking
about my character in Isle of Dogs my
job
to be devoted to love and to devotion
itself and help the little boy find his
lost dog
what is Jeff Goldblum doing well that's
a good question it's too deep to go into
it here
what is Jeff Goldblum is IQ ha I've
never had tested but it's somewhere
between 30 and 197 when was Jeff
Goldblum ever good or funny that's what
I said Oh No
when is Jeff Goldblum born when was 1952
October 22 okay when did Jeff Goldblum
when did you get married well I've been
married thrice the last time and the
most wonderful time that's left me still
intoxicated with ecstasy is with Emily
now Goldblum and it was November 8th
three years ago at the Chateau Madame
ole
oh no when did Jeff go to a host SNL I
did it twice once I think 1993 around
the time of Jurassic Park and then again
a couple of years later and vote was the
musical guest free your mind the rest
will follow
be colorblind don't be so shallow what
car does Jeff Goldblum oh no what does
he drive what car
well right now I'm driving a Prius I
like the colors I'm not a car / oh
there's more I was done why did Jeff
Goldblum leave law and order
well I'd had sufficient two years a very
full full platter of cases I scored a
hundred there wasn't a case I didn't
solve and it seemed like I'd done all I
can do to Jesco him win an Oscar I
didn't win an Oscar I was nominated for
an Oscar for directing a movie called
little surprises solo short short film
oh how did Jeff Goldblum meet Emily
Livingstone well we were at Equinox in
on Sunset Boulevard the gym and I saw
her from across a crowded room and I
marched up to her in track
began some kind of conversation ah is
Isle of Dogs the best movie ever made
yes
oh is it claymation now it's not
claymation its stop-motion animation and
wait till you see it knock your knock
your eyes where is I love dogs where
well it's in every theater at near you
you know coming to march 20 23rd is I
love dogs in congestion zone I think you
left out an article there I don't know
what congestion zone you're talking
about there's something's been going
around and I've had a congestion zone
around here ok so I love dogs based on a
book I would say no if this is an
original script original material by mr.
what mr. Wes Anderson Roman Coppola and
Jason Schwartzman I love dogs I get it
it's not a question it's not even a
statement but it is a riddle I love dogs
I love dogs I love dogs I love dogs I
love dogs I love dogs I love dogs I love
dogs you know I didn't noted that that
was there was any I didn't make this
connection until we were sent in the
publicity sky and I read the script and
I did the recording and then I went hey
I'll have dot I love dogs I love dogs I
went you know I'm big I'm an idiot and I
think we've come to the end of our
seminar for today thank you for joining
me Jeff Goldblum in this wired
autocomplete interview that's a big
handle for such a sweet little game